is it worth just buying the ipad air and  saving some money over just going for  the more expensive ipad pro and the way  i'm gonna conclude this is by mentioning  three main differences between the two  the first thing is of course the usbc  port where we actually have thunderbolt  on the ipad pro now this is actually  going to be a big deal for all the  people out there who care about  thunderbolt but for the common man this  new usb type c port with up to 10  gigabits per second is honestly fast  enough now the second thing is actually  the speakers and if you really care  about speakers the ones on the ipad pro  are quite a bit better the third thing  is the 120 hertz promotion tech on the  ipad pro and i would honestly say that  this by itself  is worth the extra 150 to 200 for the  ipad pro because it makes it feel like  it's a lot snappier if you care about  any of those three things that i  mentioned go for the ipad pro